[Music]
chocolates and mints are enjoyed by many
people
then someone discovered putting the two
together makes for a delicious
experience
the cool zestiness of the mint offsets
the rich creaminess of the chocolate
it is one of the sweetest matches in
candy history
[Music]
chocolate or mint with a chocolate mint
the decision is easy
because the two flavors are wrapped into
one
to make chocolate mints they pump liquid
sugar into a heated mixer
and add granular sugar
the mixer blends it into simmering syrup
exiting through strainers
then it's moved into a vacuum sealed
cooker
it sucks out moisture and the syrup
thickens to a jelly-like consistency
[Music]
a worker transfers it to a second mixer
and adds the mint flavoring
thorough mixing thickens it and lightens
the color substantially
[Music]
he transfers the mint flavored candy to
a work table
powerful mechanical arms massage the
slab to cool and harden the candy
[Music]
next a hopper funnels the candy into
pressurized rollers
that squeeze it into a long sheet
the sheet rides an inclining conveyor
once it reaches the top an employee
wraps the end around a long steel tube
[Music]
the tube revolves and twists them in
candy around it
the long candy sheet takes the shape of
the tube
[Music]
they melt and mix chunks of pure
chocolate with cocoa
powdered milk and icing sugar
[Music]
they add coconut oil and licithen to
bind the ingredients
once mixed the employee transfers it to
a hopper
next to the big mint candy tube
[Music]
from here the chocolate is injected into
the hollow of the mint candy tube
[Music]
the tube rolls off the forming cylinder
and passes by rollers that squeeze the
diameter down to a rope size
[Music]
a compactor then mashes the candy rope
to give the filling a honeycomb texture
pullers now stretch a second slab of
mint candy until it thickens
and turns a lighter color
the worker cuts it into chunks that fit
into the next rolling machine
it presses the candy into a sheet which
then lands on top of the mint chocolate
[Music]
the two layers now enter the next
forming machine
this one wraps the outer layer around
the chocolate infused one
creating a chocolate filled mint tube
[Music]
rollers reduce the diameter to half an
inch in size
[Music]
next the chocolate mint rope enters a
die cutter
it shapes and cuts the rope into mitts
[Music]
the mints spill into a spreader which
distributes them
evenly across a perforated conveyor
fans blow air through the holes in the
conveyor to cool and solidify the
candies
once the candies have hardened they head
to the wrapping station
here they ride a rotating circular
platform and fall into candy-sized slots
glossy metallized film wrap unwinds
mechanical arms collect the chocolate
mints as they fall out of the slots
they hold the candies for wrapping while
devices twist the ends
it takes only a fraction of a second to
wrap a candy
then it's on to a weigh station scales
release the individually wrapped
chocolate mints in increments they fall
into bags
ready for retail
[Music]
approximately 2 400 chocolate mints are
made every minute at this factory
two flavors in one candy they're quite a
treat
you